gênée elle m'a contacté et m'a dit tiens
monsieur gros est ce que tu voudrais pas
tester nos derniers écouteurs avec
réduction de bruit active moi j'ai dit
bon écoute et pourquoi pas s'est jamais
testé de produits de jbl donc je suis un
garçon curieux je dis allez go on y va
c'est donc aujourd'hui une vidéo qui
réalisé en partenariat avec jbeil pour
découvrir ce tout nouveau produit la
coupe là il vient de s'ouvrir non c'est
pas le but ce tout nouveau produit le
tout nouveau produit là c'est le jbl
life propulse tws mais pourquoi non si
compliqué pour un produit très cool oui
le produit cool je vais tous vous les
tailles et tout vous expliquer il a une
particularité il a plusieurs
particularités qui font sa force son
originalité
on va donc s'ouvrir aujourd'hui c'est si
noté l'un parce que je ne sors pas jb ça
c'est facile c'est la marque je connais
je connais depuis longtemps donc j'ai
bel light pro + tws voilà c'est cool on
y va on y va maintenant
[Musique]
ah j'aime beaucoup vous parlez de doute
vous parle beaucoup d'audience moment il
ya beaucoup de nouveautés plein de
produits super intéressant à voir tous
les côtés ici c'est un produit jbl qui
ne connaît pas gibel allez dites le moi
dites le moi je pense que si vous vous
intéressez à l'audio jbl est un des
incontournables on connaît tous ici mais
si vous ne connaissez pas voulu marquer
si vous connaissez vous le remarquez
également il dit noah et dites moi si
vous aimez la marque sibel allez on y va
à vos claviers vos commentaires on y va
en bambara vous avez trois secondes 1 2
3 vous y êtes allé go on y va tout
nouveau produit djibel il voulait
regarder up s'ouvre comme ça ton de
magie par n'a pas passé sympa avant de
vous montrer dont on va se positionner
là on va tous regardés vous allez voir
c'est vachement sympa alors j'ai déjà
ouverts vous en douterez il faut les
tester avant de vous en parler bien
évidemment ce produit là il coûte le
prix de 179 euros
c'est dans le bon sens dans le bon sens
179 euros donc plutôt bien positionnée
sont pas les moins chers se sont pas non
plus les plus chers mais c'est un tarif
qui est très normal et très correct pour
des écouteurs avec de la réduction de
bruit active avec plein de choses avec
une super application qu'on va regarder
qui est vraiment super intuitif on va la
regarder on va tous détails c'est super
bien et on va se parler de dieu oui on
va spa d'audio alors moi la première
chose qui m'a surpris ici ce qui est un
un petit détail pour vous c'est que
lorsque j'ai ouvert mon petit boîtier il
n'y avait pas les écouteurs ils étaient
cachés ils étaient cachés à l'intérieur
je vous montrais ça dans quelques
instants
à côté de ça et tout cas super important
c'est la tenue oui la tenure à des gros
zoom sur mes oreilles regardez c'est un
petit buzz bonne chose positionne comme
ça vous prenez up et après vous vissé
dans l'oreille cliquards deux tours vous
êtes vie c'est donc ça c'est vachement
bien la tenue elle est super bonne ça se
positionne extrêmement facilement ce que
j'aime bien est ce que j'ai trouvé super
intéressant en fait en application c'est
la façon de voir tout paramétrer très
facile moi si je vais vous montrer un
jeu garde un petit peu le suspense parce
que c'est une partie que j'ai vraiment
beaucoup aimé je sais pas si vous le
savez alors dites-le moi si vous le
savez ou si vous le saviez pas qu'il ya
beaucoup d'écouteurs qui n'ont pas
d'applications dédiées et je trouve que
souvent c'est des choses qui manquent
notamment le fait de pouvoir avoir un
équaliseur ici vous avez la complète oui
il se moque pas de bouche et jbl les
écouteurs sont bien tiennent bien
lorsque vous les mettez dans vos
oreilles dans l'appli faisait même un
petit guide
pour venir voir ce qu'ils sont bien
positionnés si vous voulez perdre et que
vous les égarés dans le canapé voulait
glissé sous le siège je sais pas quoi et
bien vous pouvez les retrouver très
facilement donc à plein de choses on se
regarde sans dans quelques-uns
voilà ça c'est la boîte très efficace
sympa vous prenez vous lever vous avez
des petites informations donc ça s'est
super bien et vous retrouvez votre
boîtier là vous l'ouvrez il est vide il
faut venir lever ici et vous écouteurs
sont planqués ici c'est pour ça qu'on
les voit par transparence de l'autre
côté vous venez leur charge et ici en
usb c'est donc assez plutôt bien et vous
avez bien évidemment des petites tailles
d'embouts en silicone parce que ouais il
en faut pour toutes les oreilles
donc là je puis vous assurer que quelle
que soit la forme de votre foi quelle
que soit la taille de votre oreille
vous allez trouver votre bonheur c'est
obligatoire il y en a tellement que ils
ont pensé à tout le monde ici vous avez
des petits transducteurs dynamiques et
petit haut parleur dynamique cdu 11 mm
la qualité est au rendez vous ces leçons
signature gidel je sais pas si vous
connaissez jbl je sais pas si vous aimez
jb je vous déjà demandé j'ai d'ailleurs
regret tout de suite dans les
commentaires de la rue parce qu'au
moment où je fais la vidéo je ne peux
pas y aller commentaires puisque vous ne
les avez pas encore écrit enfin peu
voyage dans le futur et dans le passé on
a un vrai son signée jbl j'ai pas de ça
vous parle sont signés gibel seront pas
notées ici si vous voulez c'est que on a
une bonne qualité audio
c'est très honnête ça marche vraiment
bien si c'est du bluetooth 5.0 nous
allons souvent passant de 20 m à 20000
hertz un très grand standard le point
positif ici que vous allez trouver je
voulais 10 et de la réduction de bruit
active alors qu'est ce que c'est de la
réduction de bruit elle tisse si vous
connaissez pas on a deux choses la toute
première c'est la réduction de bruit pas
si vous les prenez vos petits dans les
oreilles ça vaut bloc l'oreille elle
sombre ou passives comme si vous mettiez
vaudois dans vos oreilles ok ça marche
et la réduction proactive c'est un
système logiciel si vous voulez en fait
ce qui se passe et vous avez deux micros
à l'extérieur et yannick rault
l'intérieur il va venir faire un petit
peu le différentiel entre le sont à
l'extérieur et le son qu'ils
restituaient à l'intérieur pour venir
annuler les fréquences qui viennent de
l'extérieur et vous isolez vous aura
même un petit peu dans votre bulle donc
ici la réduction de bruit active marche
bien résultat est vraiment honnête vous
éléments fn d'amplification du son
ambiant qui va venir capter le son bien
qu'à venir vous le mettre dans vos
oreilles
l'histoire de pouvoir à entendre tout ce
qui se passe autour de vous de pouvoir
avoir une conversation si on le souhaite
donc ça ça fonctionne bien une fois de
plus c'est très honnête et le boulot de
gibel là dessus est vraiment bien fait
bien de la crise et donc la qualité
audio est bonne pour écouter différents
styles de musique une fois de plus ça on
va me dire modifier et le module est
directement depuis son application la
qualité pour les appels audio bien si ça
marche bien
maintenant ya un pas qui est vraiment
bien c'est que je vienne se connecter
très rapidement et très facilement
regarder je les prends je les ouvre et
vous le voyez ça vous le marquis s'y
sont connectées jb light pro plus voilà
ok on est connecté
donc pas besoin de plus alors il faut
les appéré la première fois bien
évidemment mais après ça marche
facilement et ça c'est très très cool
alors vous avez une application c'est
l'application gmail et funk je clique
dessus
et qu'est ce qui va se passer une fois
que j'ai cliqué dessus eh bien je vois
mon produit alors bon je t'ai déjà mis
c'est pour ça qu'il est là mais ce nom
pouvait venir en rajouter 1 et ensuite
je suis là donc là je vois bien
évidemment mon niveau de batterie
alors là je suis sur un smartphone avec
un très grand écran mais tel que chez
vous ça possible niveau de batterie des
deux écouteurs niveau de la recharge
ok et là tout de suite qu'est ce que je
vois une grande bande en bas qui vient
tient bon gars et l'equalizer alors
comme ça tire mon regard claque je
clique et je regarde alors là je me suis
fait un équaliseur personnalisés mais
sinon eh bien j'en ai différents jeux
jazz j'ai vocal g basse et ensuite
j'aime bien alors en fait pour créer le
mien j'ai pu ici sur plus est là et
j'aime beaucoup l'expérience vraiment je
viens balader monde doit dire oh la la
la la la la la qu'est ce que je veux
faire
donc là je me dis allez on va se monter
un petit peu les basses bon je veux pas
monter tout comme ça là je veux venir
casser un peu ma courbe
attention je la redresser donc j'appuie
là et je redresse qu'on va se monter un
petit peu ici la up
un peu plus pointu tac tac tac voyez
donc on fait vraiment ce qu'on veut
c'est super pratique vous l'appelez
comme vous voulez bon ça je le fais un
peu au pifomètre donc c'est pas le truc
le plus dingue du monde mais voyez si je
veux venir casser une fréquence elle
vient je peux et en plus qui est
vachement bien c'est qu'en plus ça vous
marque là la fréquence sur laquelle je
suis là une fois que j'ai fait dit faire
n'importe quoi avec mon équaliseur alors
j'ai fait n'importe quoi mais vous
pouvez faire des choses très très bien
vous avez de la réduction de bruit alors
là j'ai les écouteurs sur les oreilles
je vous cache pas je n'entends pas grand
chose mais en fait j'ai différents bois
des singes trouve ça hyper hyper malin
alors là que votre quotidien ça vient
bloquer un petit peu tous les bruits
environnants beau c'est hyper hyper
classique mode voyage histoire devenir
vraiment bourriner et de bloquer au
maximum du maximum
et puis un mode actif agréable comme
vous le marque lors des activités en
plein air après ce qu'il faut savoir
c'est que la réduction de bruit active
ça vient manger un petit peu au niveau
du spectre audio lorsque vous à l'écouté
de la musique forcé
c'est numérique donc si vous voulez
profiter d'une meilleure qualité
d'écouté bien vous l'a coupée mais si
vous êtes en déplacement ou dans les
transports et compagnie ça ça va être
vraiment pratique et après vous avez le
contrôle du son ambiant garde et hop la
jeune active à h m tout de suite
beaucoup mieux donc là c'est ce qu'ils
appellent l'ambiante aware je suis aware
je suis conscient ce qui passe autour de
moi et lorsque je veux dire par là
quelqu'un j'active le talk to talk fou
fou cole trou ça veut dire en fait
injecter un peu plus de son haut niveau
de mes écouteurs pour avoir une
conversation un peu naturel alors je
suis pas hyper hyper fan de ce système
là pour moi pour venir discuter c'est
pas terrible on les enlève et ont parlé
puis d'un point de vue social ça me
paraît quand même un peu mieux mais par
contre tout ce système là à la voyait en
bientôt were c'est vachement bien
lorsque vous êtes en ville en train de
vous baladez vous voulez savoir ce qui
se passe lorsque vous les traversées
vous êtes vraiment au courant et au fait
de ce qui se passe autour de vous donc
ça c'est très rassurant
et pour profiter de la meilleure qualité
audio quand même vous désactivez tout
l'électronique et là vous allez profiter
vraiment dans le style qui va être
beaucoup plus large et bien meilleure
qualité
ces deux options là je trouve vraiment
bien il marche très bien mais ça c'est
la règle pour tous les écouteurs à
réduction de bruit ou avec ce système
audio amplifiées mais dans l'ensemble ça
marche vraiment bien et après vous
n'avez pas d'autres petites options qui
vont située juste la regarder dans vos
paramètres alors mouvement ça ça me
plaît bien
c'est en fait là les paramétrages de vos
pavés tactiles là je vois que à gauche
et bien j'ai mis mon assistant google et
à droite
eh bien j'ai mis à lecture/pause double
appui puis suivant tribe l'appui piste
précédente et ensuite me dire accroché
décrocher alors ce que j'aime bien ici
déjà c'est que c'est très très clair et
très lisible on voit vraiment où on en
est donc ça c'est vraiment vraiment
vraiment top
et puis on peut venir changer on peut
venir choisir contrôle du sang bouillant
contrôle du volume assistant vocal ou
alors absolument rien donc moi j'ai mis
ici sur la gauche
mon assistant vocal mais si je le veux
pas que je me trouvais vraiment bien
c'est le contrôle du son ambiant en
europe la tac tac je change
j'appuie une fois réduction bruit
ambiant tout est rare et 2 fois top sous
active et old-school désactivé et puis
l'appuyons ça va être pour mon assistant
vocal bah ouais ce que je peux l'avoir
mais là comme je suis sur samsung
ça sera un big ben dit donc ça c'est
vachement bien je venais faire la même
chose également sur le le commande du
son je peux monter le volume je peux
baisser le volume
je trouve ça vraiment hyper hyper
pratique donc ça ça me plaît bien au
style s'il va me proposer un arrêt
automatique ou pâle dont moi je le fais
jamais j'écoute tout le temps de la
musique lecture pause automatique
lorsque vous la retirez votre assistant
vocal vous choisissez ce que vous
je vous le dis entre amazon et alexa ou
alors google assistant alors si vous
voulez cochet je dirais le point un
petit peu négatif
par exemple je viens sélectionné suis là
j'ai forcément obligé de l'assigner à
l'écouteur gauche ou droit et par défaut
si je n'avais pas été là j'aurais
notamment ici bixby bon ça il faut le
savoir
ensuite j'ai une option je trouve super
bien j'ai fait lorsque je les ai
paramétrer vérifier mon maintien
donc je les mets dans mes oreilles
j'appuie s'annonce une petite musique et
samedi simon maintien et bien voyez tout
de suite la salle mais de la musique
dans les oreilles vous l'entendez pas
mais moi je l'entends donc là il en
train de faire le test il demande de ne
pas me déplacer et là il me dit que mon
nom google s'est bien ajusté mais celui
de droit il faut changer la taille je
parle donc forcément chez les mouvements
de la mandibule c'est le bazar
mais je puis vous assurer qu'en tout cas
dans les deux cas il marche super bien
et puis ensuite j'ai un truc qui est
vachement gars s'est trouvé les
écouteurs lorsque je les ai perdus voyez
j'ai puis là olala ça couine dans mon
oreille gauche je la retrouve alors
attention pensez bien à l'enlever de vos
oreilles sinon vous allez faire comme
moi vous allez vous rendre saut mais
sinon voulais retrouver très facilement
et puis après vous avez la version de
votre micro logiciel de l'aide si vous
souhaitez avoir un petit peu d'être des
conseils et compagnie donc ça c'est
vraiment bien fait et d'un point de vue
logiciel c'est toujours la très grosse
force de produits comme celui d'avoir
une belle application bien aboutie est
très facile à utiliser
donc là dessus un grand bravo à gibert
est à noter ici au niveau d'autonomie
lorsque vous avez la réduction de bruit
active qui est enclenchée vous monter
jusqu'à 6 heures d'autonomie avec un
buzz et vous monter jusqu'à 18 heures
grâce au boîtier est par contre si vous
désactivez la réduction proactive vous
monter jusqu'à 7 heures des côtes avec
votre buzz et 21h avec votre boîtier
boîtier de recherche qui se recharge
directement l'induction c'est de la
charge compatible cuit pour dix minutes
de rechange pour partez pour une heure
donc ça c'est aussi très pratique
en plus de ça oui ça ne s'arrête pas là
ces écouteurs sont certifiés ipx4 alors
le ipx4 certifié résistants la
transpiration la sueur si vous allez
quoi vous faites du sport que vous
pouvez faire du sport avec ça va être
résistance il pleut un petit peu mais
pour autant ils ne sont pas faits pour
aller nager dans la piscine avec alors
il ya quelques couleurs qui existe moi
j'ai le noir c'est simple c'est basique
s'annonce bien il reste en rose en blanc
et or donc en ce moment le noir pour moi
ton show bien d'ailleurs dit moi vous
quelle couleur pour être plus vous
plaire en bas dans les commentaires
alors écoutez c'est la première fois que
je découvrir et tester des petits
écouteurs comme ça de gibel des
écouteurs avec réduction de bruit active
bravo gibel j'aime beaucoup je trouve
très honnête c'est vrai que sur ce
marché des écouteurs des trouvailles en
laisse
vous en avez un paquet il y en a
beaucoup
de tous les côtés ici je dirais que le
gros point fort est bien c'est qu'on
vient s'appuyer sur le savoir-faire de
jbl le produit est super bien super
efficace très bonne réduction d'objectif
pour 179 euros avec un vrai savoir faire
maîtrisé par jbl donc si vous cherchez
des écouteurs et que vous aimez jbl et
que vous voulez de la réduction
proactive et que vous avez un budget un
petit peu en dessous des 180 euros et
bien vous pouvez le match et ici c'est
un match c'est beau bravo gibel moi
j'aime beaucoup
a vous de me dire vous ce que vous en
pensez en main aux commentaires est ce
que ça pourrait voir ip ces petits
écouteurs du belge en a beaucoup il y en
a beaucoup on parle de beaucoup de duos
en ce moment parce que ils en font un
peu pour tout le monde il ya plein de
belles propositions mais c'est vrai que
celle ci aussi me plaît beaucoup aimé
ait intéressant a vous de me dire ce que
vous en pensez en bar en commentaire sur
ceux des gros bisous beaucoup d'amour
qu'on essaie de vous et à très bientôt
ciao